it hasn't happened already I guarantee
that after this movie comes out middle
schools and elementary schools
everywhere will have kids singing the
afro circus song it is inevitable
Madagascar 3 is the third film in this
trilogy and you know I have really been
a huge fan of the series I always
thought they were fine they were
passable films I never really thought
they were the greatest pieces of
animated entertainment but they
certainly weren't awful we pick up our
story with the for animals voice by Ben
Stiller Giada Pinkett Smith David
Schwimmer and Chris Rock they're fleeing
from the greatest Huntress ever it's
this woman who has the head of like
every animal on her wall except for a
lion which is why she's after them they
stole away on a circus train end up
taking over the circus changing the
whole circus lineup and they become
friends with all these people in the
circus train as they go through Europe
as I said in my intro the Madagascar
films had never really been my favorite
animated films I always thought they
were fine and so I wasn't really looking
forward to seeing this movie I kind of
went to the screening with a little bit
of reluctance and to my very pleasant
surprises movie really isn't that bad I
had a lot of fun with this movie this
one isn't just a kids movie it has a lot
of jokes that adults will understand
things that are going to go over very
young children's heads and adults are
going to be happy about but it's not
just that this is actually a really well
directed movie like the action sequences
in this movie are actually pretty
exciting and there's a lot of them too I
was actually surprised how much fun I
had with this movie it was actually not
bad at all all the voice acting all
around the board is really good
especially Martin Short as this sea lion
he is hilarious in this movie he is
really funny in this movie too and Sasha
Baron Cohen is great he plays the
dancing lemur who does the movement move
it song that kids are obsessed with it
seems like every time a Madagascar movie
comes out there's like a new song the
kids are singing in school this one has
afro circus the film also has a nice
sense of heart to it as well there's a
tiger character that's introduced and
you learn things about his past you kind
of feel for that tiger you want him to
succeed in his circus dreams and
everything and I don't want to get too
much into what happens like they're
actually his character development in
this movie it's very surprising to me
it's co-written by Noah Baumbach he's a
good writer and I was surprised that he
was involved with this movie and it
shows because the characters in this
movie like you they actually had depth
now the Madagascar movies exist in a
different world than some of the more
sophisticated animated films like say
Toy Story exist the Madagascar movies
are definitely more in a cartoon-like
world the Toy Story movies were more in
some sort of a physical world where you
actually got a sense of like physics and
everything
and that kind of stuff exists Madagascar
more inhabits that loony-tunes world
where people can just bust through walls
and be perfectly fine Lions are doing
flips on trapeze and stuff like
obviously that doesn't happen in real
life and once you realize and go with
that you can kind of accept a lot of the
incredibly impossible things that happen
in this movie also the villain character
this Huntress that's after them really
strong villain like I really liked her
she had like a lot of Comedy Tour and
she was really intense as well like she
was a good action heroine also the 3d in
this movie is excellent the depth of
field is very well done and lots of
things pop out of you and it was
extremely three-dimensional like it
actually was 3d I rarely ever do this
and it's usually just with animated
films but I would recommend that you
actually see this movie in 3d rather
than 2d I think the 3d actually lends to
the film I think it's good for the movie
and it was really well done I laughed a
lot in the movie there were jokes that
worked it's just a fun time really
there's nothing overtly special about
the movie you'll probably forget about
it soon unless you're a very very young
kid like maybe like 10 and under you'll
probably love this movie and watch it
and thusly as you grow up it's difficult
really to identify like one problem with
this movie it's just that it's not a
great film it is a fun family time of
the movies but once you leave you'll
probably feel good about yourself but
it's not like you're gonna really think
about it ever again probably it is you
know a little bit sappy as well like
there's certain romance plots that the
film tries to develop it doesn't really
feel terribly genuine but to be honest
this is just a fun time for the family
at the movies I was surprised by
Madagascar through I'm going to give it
a B so I'd like to know what's a film
that you guys ended up seeing
reluctantly but actually really
surprised you let me know in the
comments below and as always guys if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]